you should get therapy though you should
maybe you should get 30 years old
because you said they're acting like
you're some Superior sort of woman these
times you you really know I say I say as
I've said I am not Superior I'm not
better the reason I'm saying for the
fact that you think you should go get
therapy is the problem I think that
because of what you said you said you
pick toxic men because of you when I
attracted one denalvo wait wait can you
wait till I finish you said you pick
toxic men because of your daddy okay you
stayed with a toxic guy for five years
because of daddy issues right okay you
said the way you fixed that was talking
to your male friends
okay and I went to therapy for a little
bit I I think that that you should go to
therapy to solve it to a male therapist
it's just based off of what you said
okay I'm not saying this to attack you
personally I'm not saying I'm better
don't get triggered I'm saying this
based on the information you gave me
okay and now I'll explain something to
you my sister here's why you're wrong
Pearl no no it's not why she's wrong
it's just so that she can understand the
person that she's speaking to because a
lot of the time we sit in these
situations and we take people for face
value and a lot of the time I listen to
what you say yeah that's okay that's
okay it's still on the surface because
it's the same way that people see me on
this camera and they assume that I'm the
biggest [__] in these times I'm
actually really nice and very friendly
and very Smiley do you see what I mean
so people shouldn't take things for face
value let me tell you something as the
person that I am and as the person that
is as inquisitive as I am and when to
learn why I got myself into that
situation why it happened and actually
I've done a lot of things and I've put a
lot of systems around me to make sure
that I'm not only protected but also I'm
educating myself every single day and
growing as a Woman
based on what you said you seem scared
wait wait okay
you're saying that you want separate
houses this this is not someone that's
going into a relationship in good faith
if I were you I would go see a male
therapist that's that's it I don't you
could you can say I'm wrong you don't
have to go that's just my two cents you
don't have to I don't need to I don't
need it so that's okay I want to ask you
this to know but so then given your
perspective on things like what at you
should you're 31 at the screen 30. okay
guys you can be 31 this year or next
year this year when's your birthday
December are you Sagittarius yes sir me
too when's your birthday the second
seventh really
but listen let me so run this past me
you're 30 right clearly intelligent
woman you know you have a backbone very
strong backbone
what is your mating strategy moving
forward
what do you mean how am I gonna how will
I find the men how are you gonna acquire
it what do you want first do you want do
you want children do you want family uh
I
I would like to have two children two
yeah okay Max okay so you wanna have two
children Max and
how do you plan to acquire a man
with your given skill set
um I don't plan on acquiring a man so I
think people make a mistake of looking
for something when that something will
come I'm very much aware of the fact
that I'm building myself up to be
somebody that will attract a type of
person okay so whether I'm intelligent
whether I'm rich or poor whether I'm
sitting on these cameras whatever it is
none of this is my real life none of
this is who I am this is not even a
fraction of the entire person that I am
so I don't need to look realistically
like this it's not a joke when I tell
you that I'm single by choice there's a
lot of men around me that I believe are
fantastic men that really are interested
in being with a woman like me but I am
not interested especially not at this
point where I believe that I need to
take my time to be able to settle myself
before I go into a relationship do you
see what I mean and then not only that
through this spirit and through being in
that relationship and through
understanding things with much more
Clarity I fully understand the fact that
as human beings forget about man and
woman as human beings we're actually
much more complex than people realize
and Villa and a lot of the time we're
forcing ourselves to be in situations
that are just not conducive for our own
individual mental well-being so what if
what if like uh what if like an
attractive like successful man
was to say hey I'm interested in you
what would you do
okay like let's talk
but at the same time you said you're not
looking for it so I don't know because
you because I'm confused because you
said on one hand
I want to get married I want to have two
children but at the same time you're
like but I'm not gonna look for it so
how are you going to find something that
you're not looking for because I don't
need to look for it
I believe in faith whatever will be will
be I don't need to try and control this
situation because the more you control
it the more you try usually the more you
end up in the wrong situation because
something that looks like it's amazing
may just not be okay so on that one I
definitely disagree because I have never
seen somebody in my 37 years of being
alive who has put their entire effort
into trying to get something literally
all around for day in and day out and
not get it well I think that you'll find
a lot of the time especially when it
comes to girls and they feel they fall
under the pressure like oh I need to
find somebody they end up finding the
wrong person because the desperation or
the pressure makes you make the wrong
decision so for me I would much rather
work on being a healthier and happier
human being so that when the time does
come I'm more than ready do you have any
evidence I see what you're saying like
they're saying if they look for a man
they look for a relationship they're too
desperate and they end up getting in a
bad situation right but have you seen
that happen yes okay so how do you also
seen a woman who says I'm not going to
be a hoe I'm going to buckle down I'm
gonna go find a good man and find a good
man and get married and have family and
have relationships have you seen that
too
[Music]
yeah
I think it depends on luck as well luck
is definitely part of it for sure
because personally like I wasn't dating
for like two years I wasn't even looking
because the relationship I had before
was so strong I moved countries so I
couldn't see that person so I was
holding on to that I didn't sorry
um so like my relationship like I wasn't
looking to find somebody else when I
moved countries for the person I was
dating for like four years
um I was like I didn't want to see
anybody else I was just used to that so
like I wasn't trying I think it just
sort of happened I met someone after
like two years it was so weird like he
saw me on Snapchat map and he was like
do you want to have dinner how I'm sorry
lunch like on Snapchat how old are you
again 21 yeah okay yeah so he met me on
Snapchat you have different privileges
at 21 than you do at 30. yeah okay I'm
not talking about being 30 but I'm just
saying I like a long-term relationship I
don't like to happen no no no I'm saying
like like I'm saying that we're saying
you're younger and hotter now and 10
years I'm trying to get married as well
like now I'm younger I'm working like
really hard I'm trying to like I just
look talk to myself for so long that I
cannot I how do I put this I don't have
the opportunity to sleep I don't have
the opportunities that I can just go
mess around because if I say I want to
go pie and have fun right now I'm gonna
be on the street because there's no
one's gonna pay my rent my mom is not
gonna say let me send you money do you
know I mean I don't have that privileges
to mess up so it's like I feel like I
have my things sorted out now I'm
thinking like I'm gonna get a job I'm
saving money I'm gonna get a mortgage I
want to do that I want to be married I
want to find somebody and hopefully like
luckily for me like I'm with somebody
right now we're not in the richest part
of where we're supposed to be because
we're young you know I mean we're not
expecting the biggest one I'm obviously
I know that I'm pretty I that's what I
say myself you are very pretty I can go
outside right now and I could be like I
could go on Instagram my Instagram it's
not that but I could see I won that man
I could go out and I try my hardest to
get like you know a guy who's 10 10 or
something like that so I'm not looking
for that you're in you're in a
relationship yeah so when when would you
like to be married be personally I've
been saying I want to be married in like
when I'm 25 I want to be like because I
feel like but then does he know that you
want to be married oh yeah
does he also want to be married yeah but
like people want to get married to each
other with stuff like that like we say
all the time so he he wants to be
married too yeah he's invented this
right now it's so weird okay now so
what's that what's that what's the hold
up um how long have you been dating oh
so we've been dating for like two years
um like what in a month or a couple
weeks is the hold up like if why don't
you just go we're young like do you know
what I mean like we have different he's
he's young he's just like you know I
mean we have things but we're working
towards saying things I want a nice
drink he wants something nice as well
we're working to get that so I like
Amanda I grew up with I like a man
that's good but me I don't want
something already made because it's like
I don't know that person or like I don't
know I'm gonna say oh because I have all
of this you can listen to me I'll tell
you this though like uh having a nice
ring is not nearly as important as
having a decent person in your life and
I think that's something because a lot
of people when you're in a relationship
too I I fell victim to this too yeah I
was in such a good relationship that I
got comfortable and I realized like oh
well if things don't work out with her I
can just go find the other perfect
amazing girl and then now I'm out here
in the streets with all these [__]
hookers everywhere and it's hard as hell
to find a decent woman out there because
you know I was completely lost in
understanding the fact that I had
something good we have it right in front
of you so don't get too caught up I'll
just tell you this as a guy who's older
than you who's done a little bit more
than you don't get too caught up in the
materialism things saying I need this I
need that and just focus on what you
really really want like when you're
about to lie when you're in your
deathbed you're not going to be like
well you know what I lived a good life
and God damn it
what a nice ring I've got on my face
sort of uh
uh Samuels talk to women
they would talk about how like these
women people would be dating for one two
years and he's like why don't you just
get married
and I I and what I realized is the point
he was getting at is like women
oftentimes want the ring in the wedding
but they don't want the marriage right
and so like they'll they'll hold off to
get married when it's like you can get a
bigger ring later
but um yeah I don't know I'm not saying
I don't want to get ring now but like
I'm 21. he's like the same like he's
sweating how many kids do you want um I
want two kids because like I want to be
able to have the resources to take care
of them but like we're growing we'll
yeah I know I know him obviously yeah
but we learn a lot about it I know him
enough you know what I mean would I want
to get married to 21 no because I want
to work I want to end money I want him
to do that as well like I'm not together
I'm just saying like a lot of times they
sell you that you need to wait to get
married and I don't really think you do
no you really I'm not selling that not
just the choice I'm saying like in the
media the corporation delicious it's
just a choice like I don't do I want to
be married no no I want to I still want
to end money I still want to go to work
I still want to be able to why can't you
earn money while you're married because
if I'm married yeah knowing myself I'm
such a family-oriented person like I
didn't really like have siblings growing
up I grew up with my family so if I get
my I feel like I'll forget every other
thing I'll get too comfortable I just
want to be home and take care of my kids
I want to see them running around that's
right and now that's what I want to do
what do you do
um right now um so I work for Costco as
a brand ambassador for Costco but I
recently what about basketball what is
what is that it's a brand ambassador so
like could you see brand of Alexa and
it's like a how do I put an advertise
certain products for Costco
yeah I recently got a new job like as an
air hostess I don't know if this is
gonna like to fly so yeah but like you
know it's like I've gone through stuff
like a lot of that but I was like I just
have a certain plan in my head yeah but
it's like okay you're gonna be a sky
waitress
no no not a bad thing not a bad thing
but I'm just saying like wouldn't
wouldn't it be better to spend that
energy on your kids yeah but yeah I you
can you know what it sounds to me like
you're economically afraid like if you
give up the opportunity to be you know
an employee or something along those
lines that you might have no money and
you might be I wonder
I want to be financially stable it's
just a normal everybody
let's just say this if I was with
somebody if my boyfriend just happened
to be like super rich Let's just say if
he was a stable person I would be
married right now like it would not be
myself tomorrow but because if I'm
getting if I got married now and had a
kid what's what's going to happen to my
kids what are we gonna do we're just
gonna cuddle all night well I'll tell
you this you're gonna find more comfort
and love and and fulfillment in sticking
together as a couple as you both grind
to the top I like right that that is one
of the most strong emotional bonds
you'll ever build with someone right
dude I'm doing so much good work for you
and your boyfriend right now your
boyfriend he's slightly better you
better follow me on Instagram hot dude
life
um but like you know sticking with him
and you guys both building As you move
to the top is going to be far more of a
rewarding experience than you going into
that cold and heartless corporate world
where you're just a number on a
spreadsheet that if you don't do certain
things that you're just completely off
the charts I know I just want us to help
each other you know like we just gotta
help each other out because obviously it
does happen like we just get more like
we do get married in the future but if
we don't we don't well at least right
now I'm happy we're stable he's nice to
me I'm with him for two years for a
reason he's not stupid no it's not like
the man them he's not a road man he's
not like active them so I mean he's just
nice like where I come home it's
something to go back to we cook together
we laugh together we go on little walks
it's not it doesn't have to be the
fanciest thing right now but I know that
we're gonna get there because we have
the same mentality of wanting to work
harder to get something We're Young
right now we're gonna get it yes it's
nice to dream big I want a fancy thing
but yeah I don't I don't being fancy all
the money but if I'm not happy and I
don't feel comfortable lying beside the
person I'm with then it's not worth it
for me personally I don't not about
every other person out there so I'd
rather be with my little boy not my
little boy sorry my boyfriend that me
being us just being young together we
don't have any faith but we're
comfortable like he can go take me on a
date I could take him on a day we can
leave accident we can have ice creams
walking on the park and that's good
enough for me because I'm happy you know
what I mean and then one day boom we're
working right now he's a graduate now
he's going to get a lot of stuff
together we don't live together right
now I live in I live in a different
place do you live at home or with
roommates um so I live like in a shelf
flat
um he lives in a different place as well
because I was brought in a way that I
could not live with a man as well like
my mom would kill me yeah yeah because I
can't do it even if I wanted to it's not
my culture I feel like when I get
married to somebody then I'm moving no
there's a there's a pro to getting
married it's less money to pay if you're
sharing rent I know but like you know
what I mean I gotta well you couldn't
after you I'm waiting I'm waiting
okay as many of you
any of you just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible